members debated the British Parliament's  rejection of the brexit withdrawal  agreement the UK is set to leave the EU  on the 29th of March members voted to  increase funding by 19% of the European  Social Fund plus in the EU s-- next  long-term budget this will boost youth  employability and help to fight child  poverty parliament approved investi you  a new program to support financing in  infrastructure research and innovation  it should trigger almost 700 billion  euros in investments the European Fund  for transition formerly the  globalization adjustment fund helps  people who have lost their jobs as a  result of technological or environmental  changes parliament voted to lower the  threshold of eligibility to 200 jobs  lost in a company or sector a special  committee presented its report on  pesticides after nine months of  fact-finding members voted to make the e  use pesticide approval process more  transparent and accountable